and always fear is coming blood will be  on you won this movie is the biggest  mission we've ever made it's the most  epic film it has a tremendous cast  problems are enormous the action is even  bigger and it's a very personal story so  it's gonna take the audience and I think  it puts them on the edge of their seat  and will not let go even after the  credits roll this is a bad idea is it a  good one  honestly you know I've had a long  history with IMAX so it's made for IMAX  but when people are seeing this they're  gonna see practical action it's not  green screen and it's dangerous you know  yes but it's lethal you see that on the  big screen it's exhilarating you're  looking at movie like Mission Impossible  and IMAX is this scale of the movie is  enormous and when you're seeing on that  size of screen that perfect sound it is  just a different experience what are you  waiting for  I'm jumping out a window  you